good
morning Millennials Wow well low pitch
today yeah it's a low pitched sort of
day so funny I feel like we're always in
opposite positions like on a Monday I'm
like I'm dead and you're like oh it just
said like to face masks and that was
Zach so again I'm like now I just did a
face back hung out with deal all weekend
I have nothing to give you you you guys
today actually we do have something to
give you all I'm giving today is a seat
in this chair okay there's nothing more
well as per usual I will just talk don't
worry about it but this is your big day
so anything you want to say we get it in
today this is what I want to say okay
Jaggi and I are having like an HR issue
at work with our new employee if we
could cut to the snitch cam really
quickly we need to talk to you Margo
yeah and they are you a microphone yes I
think that all of our you know um
internal like workplace conversation
should be had on the show if we air it
out in like a public yeah in a public
setting I feel as if there's like proof
and we can there get in trouble with HR
but you are wearing the same shirt you
are on Thursday and you're on camera now
and you just can't pull [ __ ] like that
today don't call her it's like the new
don't warry be lucky you're always
wearing sure it's telling people what to
do okay that is that it's defensible but
I also know that you did unpack
everything because you're right I'm
sorry I know you're gonna ruin like the
masterpiece that I created okay so I'm
just wearing the things that I see at
the top I understand that I just want to
let you know it's been noted in your
file
see you and we're really like so far
like we're unhappy with this okay also I
found myself I'm like literally I'm on
death's door today
and I am making coffee for the PA Mario
and you she's like hey can you grab me a
coffee I have to go do something I was
like what I had or wipe down this table
because the Headlee your coffee rings on
it like an irritation but you know my
tissues have been long gone but there
was a bandaid on there sure there was a
band-aid okay um okay well happy Monday
everyone I hope you guys had a great
great weekend how was Colgate reunion
was it everything you had let it up
to be and more oh it was so fun like it
was so nice to be epical it like it is
truly so beautiful I love my Willis PAP
season they're the funniest people like
we're just having fun wherever we go but
as far as like what reunion was it was
not what I thought it was gonna be I
thought it was gonna be a spring party
weekend like back at College tension on
these hoes oh my god I'm accidentally
gonna do Molly like it's gonna get crazy
no it was very low-key and casual
it didn't look located on your it like
it was just like low compared to what I
had it built up in my head and there
were like some really fun events like
the best parts were the school organized
events which if you had told me that
going into it I would have never ever
liked [ __ ] knees right so it was
really fun it's like the class well
there's two cool things one it's like
five years 10 years 15 years so I was
like the class of 1979 is there and it
was cool like to see everyone else at
their reasons like you can't be doing
Molly with the kids from 1979 no but
there are different tents so there's the
2010 that's 2000 to 2019 and like man
that is totally like age shaming no but
that's where the head meet you want to
hear about age shaving there was a
singles event Julian and I just saw it
on the pamphlet and I was like oh my god
that's brilliant never thought about it
again then I saw Heather Fischbach
posted an Instagram caption saying I
went to Michael gay treating me like it
was incredible time I just want to talk
about like something I saw in the
pamphlet there was a singles event she
was like and I went to go boom put
myself out there good god she saw it was
at the seventies 10 she rolled up and
like it was weird that was at the
seventies time anyways and the person
who was like sitting guard outside the
tent was like not for you wait that
means no she had turned away from the
singles event at Colgate yeah but don't
you think the singles event would be for
the young people you would think I guess
it was for the widows and divorcees oh I
guess that's it
um but there should have been like a
young singles event as well yeah uh
anyway so the tents really had their own
things happening is what I'm saying
maybe the 2007 wasn't even the best tent
and they got a band to play Giants of
science
to play like at Colgate and they also do
weddings in seven it was just it was the
[ __ ] Catalina Wine Mixer I understood
I was I was just I lost my mind so that
was really fun it was but everything
just felt like a science of science
where it was like okay if I drink here
and eat there and breathe there and I
walk there maybe I'll live and survive
alone I was really like I was it was
like that meme where you're looking at
the math equations of like how to just
get through and it was a lot of [ __ ]
work well I'm sorry that you had such an
unpleasant weekend I know it was
pleasant
it was just tired and Wow the worst part
we stayed in the dorms which was
actually the best parks I stayed in the
dorm that I lived in my freshman year
and like we got there and it's palatial
somehow Rebecca and I got the room that
has absolutely no air Oh no ventilation
oh my god so each night we had to sit we
had to sleep with the windows all the
way open but we're on the first level
and so every morning like I'm trying to
sleep till noon here like I brought a
[ __ ] egg crate in the mattress pad
like I need to sleep every morning I
heard every single conversation
happening on the floor annoying it was
as if we were sleeping outside and then
like my allergies like my eyes every
morning were just like puffy it was so
it was just everything was a struggle
everything was a give-and-take we shut
the windows it's quiet but it's hot yeah
well my weekend was really just relaxing
almost to the point of boring and I was
just loving the feeling of being bored
snitch and I trekked all the way to
Trenton New Jersey to go to a country
concert it was Morgan Evans Old Dominion
and it was [ __ ] premium like I got
wasted because honestly the our half car
ride there and back just like didn't
help with their weapons Trenton New
Jersey I never was in Holmdel know where
we're going this weekend for Rascal
Flatts
I'm so [ __ ] excited hit the ball e
I'm on it yeah you really like what to
do Molly rascal I know I really don't
like because I just I have nothing left
to give as I've said and I really felt
as if this whole green and weekend was
like it's really the end of an era for
me like from that like I think my like
that was just the last like big hurrah
big hurrah except I guess I'm asked a
flat and we're going Bahamas and you
know we'll have anyways um I don't know
where I was I don't know what I was
gonna I don't know what the second half
to us how was the concert oh it was
amazing Old Dominion is truly like so
premium first of all that lead singer is
so hot like I was just living for him
and like on their schedule like they
have look on the schedule of the night
it's like Morgan Ivan's a 45
they have like everything like clocked
in and they also have a shot of tequila
shot at nine o'clock will chained by the
best - on their bus and then like the
hockey game on and me and Margo and so
like I was like nervous I see you - and
Men and bedspread Tomer who like loves
country music and he was just like
really appreciating like the premium
allottee of it all the VIP experience
yeah and we were like on their bus just
like chillin in their like little back
patio and we're talking the two of
members like literally number one and
number two and first of all number two's
girlfriend is a toaster like I just I
love the toaster it's like for making me
look cool all the time speaking I have
another strange to tell you about remind
me Justin Sylvester so I only can we cut
to it no wait we're talking like what
are you talking about with like
illegitimate rock stars you know what do
I talk about Jax house your chances I
was literally in a conversation about
like w-2s and 1099s and I'm like think
of myself like how do I get out of this
like I have to stop talking about taxes
and actually I feel as if they really
responded well to the tax conversation
Margo would you agree yeah the great
tagline baby felt they thought what you
were saying yeah and the day to picture
with me wow yeah it was really cool how
was morganite in City sing we dreamed he
did an ID I'm Tim before and I was like
please sing we dream and he was like
I'll try and he didn't cuz like I know
I'm not mad at him for like
reconstructing his entire set just like
one person in the audience but he's like
so talented he was onstage totally by
himself just him in his guitar and he's
like such a great voice and I just loved
him and then I had the dream about him
that night they're like him and I really
hit it off on my Kelsey was like jealous
and then also I want to say this Justin
semester thing he FaceTime me five
seconds ago and he was like I'm in Capri
and he was looking like so cute like on
the beach at the umbrellas in the great
Milan photos he's looking this girl
comes out to me and she's like you were
on the chill that I love the UM and he's
like thinking you know pop news girls
like the morning shows and he's like are
you [ __ ] kidding me I'm telling that
one and then he FaceTime me with the
girl and he was like honestly like the
twisters are everywhere like we've gone
global Capri the toasters are truly
everywhere I met so many wonderful
toasters this weekend
it's really just the best also Margot
and I saw Rocket Man oh yes five [ __ ]
stars great I'm gonna see it
week so don't say too much no I'm not
it's really that the same as Bohemian
Rhapsody I will loose a little more
Disney is that the key oh no no less
yeah it's more Jack me yeah I loved the
movie I just liked Bohemian Rhapsody
music better I'm just like more into
like the Queen vibe then the Elton John
vibe and they're both great music and
you know more than you think when they
just start singing and it's like oh yeah
yeah Danny and Margot what's the song
this thing and then about standing no
Russian um
so while I thought and by the Taron
Egerton edgerton was brilliant like just
so fantastic five stars all around great
movie highly recommend there's so many
movies I want to see now I want to see
Aladdin and I need to see bug smart just
to see if I should be offended that
everyone's comparing me to the beanie
Felton character and Margo said she saw
it and then I will be she will be
offended well she just liked Big Bob on
not even just like she's just like to
the old to see it's also just like so
not your personality at all she's like a
stuck-up like smart [ __ ] excuse me no
like yeah yeah yeah that's not yet
please I wouldn't have such a better
University than you yell inter-site um
well I believe I believe that's all is
it how was your mood counselor snitch
Marga moved into her first big-girl
apartment um it actually wasn't so bad
like with the help of the boys I'd
legitimately didn't have to lift a
finger
your husband was just integral he really
he came at the perfect time when
everything was done yeah he told me he
didn't tell any when he came with
Presidency was so cute we had already
left
oh that's so nice yeah he brought you a
lot of stuff brought me a lot of stuff
he brought me lamb / middle of the night
last night was raining he like had all
these lamps for her and like because she
doesn't have light in her apartment cuz
the building like doesn't have lights
and he brought them all to her in the
rain yeah so whatever show she was like
sitting in the dark with your friend
we're in legit saying I you need lamps
that's a problem with moving into a
rental like the first few days you don't
have blinds and you don't have lights
but thank God you have blinds yeah I do
have blinds so what's going what's going
well it's just like weird being in an
empty apartment was absolutely no
furniture like there's legitimately an
echo cuz Margaret does have a roommate
but she's vacationing
yes she's vacationing and she didn't met
you she didn't exactly Freddie but she's
backpacking um I said I love white
people spare me invitations to things
like I never want to go to like do you
ever come to my book
I've never been invited to a book club
to say no I wouldn't want to go yeah you
should start a book club but like
instead of books you're just like the
time just hang out at my house and look
at the oh there is how's the Tigs
precious as always really getting to
spend some quality time with him and I
gave him a bath with Pantene and I've
read like in beauty of the toast in some
of the beauty subgroups like Pantene's
like terrible for you like it dries out
your hair Co has never been softer or
more delicious just like I can't get
enough of him joy to come over I know
that I have to I don't know if I can you
know are you not coming over for roast I
know that I have to and it's still like
something I intend to do I just don't
know you can come out you can go okay
great okay well I believe we've wasted
enough time before oh actually no I have
one more announcement we launched our
first TNN show on Thursday and I have to
say it's been only a couple days but the
podcast when when we put it up I was
sending you screenshots of the analytics
and I'm like oh my god this show isn't
that popular it did you see it yeah it
blew up yeah so thank you everyone for
tuning and subscribing to the schvitz
it's available on Apple on Spotify
stitcher everywhere you can listen to
the toast now you can also listen to the
[ __ ] so thanks for bearing with us I
think they're thinking about moving it
to Tuesday's episode drops just cuz it's
like a better day for sports I think
that works for me
yeah just letting everyone know but
thank you guys for being so supportive
if you're not in the Facebook group yet
it's the Schmidt sirs and I'll say
that's a great way to get into the
toasters group because you can really
like lazy and no and it's like if I see
that you're part of the traitors I'll be
like oh you're a true tosser now in yeah
we listen to a bit of the chef it's an
hour drive up to Colgate
oh my god I was like really laughing I'm
some of the sports stuff like I like was
kind of familiar but they really didn't
do it like so much like in-depth sports
they just like talk like they normally
talk and I was hysterically Ben and his
friends are so weird and they have their
own language like we do know and it's
like the way that they talk about sports
is like the way that we talk about The
Bachelor and it's like you don't have to
like yes it's more interesting if you
watch the show but you don't have to
watch in order to like kind of
understand what we're saying right or
they came of Thrones like people just
listen to our recaps and don't watch the
show did you see that Alabama Hannah was
that way no tango and she had a picture
with Taylor Swift I didn't see her
picture it's her so if I saw her picture
with the toaster oh that was cherry
really she did look great
I love her like objectively objectively
I'm happy for her I know if I oh we've
in an atom I know that's our first okay
no if I like sat down watched your
season I know it's amazing and if please
stop telling me to watch it because I'm
not going to watch it only because I'm
just loving having two hours of my life
back and they're very important to me it
has nothing to do it's like having
anything against her or the show yes a
value of my time okay are you ready I'm
ready for the past five stories that you
need now before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast yes
because first up Raven and Adam are
engaged
Raven Gates and Adam got Chuck will be
saying I do soon on Sunday the bachelor
in paradise couple who got together in
season four of the bachelor and
bachelorette spin-off in 2017 announced
their engagement on Instagram quote I'm
keeping you forever and for always we
will be together all of our days want to
wake up every morning to your sweet face
dad always gates twenty-seven capturing
the collection of engagement snaps
revealing God's Chuck I had popped the
question on Friday May 31st I love them
so much I'm so happy for them I love
that it happened on Friday they have the
weekend to themselves to celebrate with
friends and family and then announced
yesterday they are just the cutest
couple I feel as if I've gotten to know
them just on the micro level and I'm
just like so here for everything they
have to offer me as a consumer as also a
potential wedding in bi t what did you
measure under your wedding [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah okay we need to just like be
like so annoying Brides maybe like
helpful yeah I wonder like I feel like
I'm always having just like Berg frets
about like people that I didn't invite
to my wedding yeah um like even like
this weekend just it's when do you ever
get out what do you ever feel that way I
have two major regrets one is a person
who I invited who I wish wasn't there
just cuz I literally hate her now and
she I ain't like really just started
becoming friends with Taylor Stryker and
I wish for so many reasons she was there
cuz like I still love her now which
means she's a true friend cuz I hate
people like they come and go and I just
hate them and I just love her and Taylor
like our whole family loves her like I
really like that's one of my major life
regrets I think we had to come friends
her like six months before because she
would have been no doubt been invited
yeah and that's your [ __ ] across to
there it's my big [ __ ] wouldn't cross
to take on the subway okay oh I was
saying oh we were saying this weekend
was it was just so how did that one
start like that cross to bear thing like
we just said it we said it once and then
it just kept being so pertinent in that
one sentence and then like when we say
something enough oh and I just kept
feeling as though all weekend yeah and
honestly like for the rest of my life
like not inviting Telstra because I like
you
you know like I feel like tell a checker
will be our friend for a really long
time like I know and I feel as though it
is truly my lifetime's cross to bear and
I'm just so upset about it so I totally
understand where you're coming through
anyway so every time like something new
comes up and now Raven and Adam I'm so
happy for them the pictures were so
beautiful premium is hefo premium is how
like she looked incredible he looks
great like there was it was a beautiful
rooftop in Dallas where you could like
see the bridge but not like the city
like seeing the congestion yeah I think
about like a city you can't see flea
bottom game a third stroke if you don't
get it no but do you know what I mean of
course about like a city view that's
King Khan you know honestly there's
something about a city view that if it's
not New York but there's something about
New York and like skyline it's like
iconic whatever and like it doesn't make
me want to throw up but like any like
industrial city with like smoke coming
out of the potholes like that it's like
there's nothing when they went to
Trenton like I was really feeling the
suburb I there's nothing worse than a
parking lot you know nothing no they
paved paradise and put up a parking lot
after this weekend like it was just so
beautiful they somebody this does like
so many [ __ ] vistas and then I came
back and just like for the luck of me
like we took the Lincoln Tunnel Rebecca
was driving down to the West Village she
was like there's nothing more depressing
rather than the Lincoln Tunnel me she
was like no this is it she was like I'm
driving back to the micelle it's like we
come in on May 14th she'd robbed you she
dropped me on 40th 112th on 40th and 8th
Wow times three a Port Authority yeah
and I was literally like rolling over
bodies thank you it was a mistake
I was just it was a better wonderful
pink away luggages Oh God now the street
just like trying not to get mugged
no it was horrific no like navigating
like welcome to New York it's been
waiting for you know navigating the
streets of New York without trying to
get like mugged or like exposed to is
truly like an Olympic sport no it was
like the single worst place I could have
been I take my vitamins every day just
so I have enough energy and spirit to
dodge the New York City muggers and
thieves and people who yell at you on
the subway I take my vitamins every day
so that I have enough energy to survive
Colgate reunion
and honestly like you need to separate
me to put in my in my care of portfolio
that I had a five-year reunion well
Karen is a subscription service that
delivers vitamins and supplements
customized for your specific health
needs you take a short quiz we love a
quiz and answer questions about your
diets the lifestyle fitness and health
goals and care of puts together a
personalized plan just for you you can
get back into a healthy routine because
Caribes online quiz lets you know
exactly what you need taking care of
your health should be easy and
convenient experience the care of
difference love care of for 25% off a
visit up for your first order visit care
of me sorry um today for 25% off your
first care of order go to take care of
calm and enter code toast TOA st the
website is take care of ta ke care of
calm enter code toast for 25% off your
first order get back into shape get back
get your mind right you know I might
even soul my friends I need that's what
I need to take instead of Molly yet
Rascal Flatts care of you know I need to
be taking like magnesium in the corners
sniffing something like hey what's that
I might know where he says might be 12
yeah well the thing I really liked about
the concert that we went to was that it
was on Saturday so I had Sunday to like
come to myself the concert that we're
going to this weekend is on Sunday there
might not be a show on Monday well also
I have to let every know there is like a
half 50% chance I'm gone all week in
which case I think maybe we should just
take a hiatus cuz we haven't done our
summer break yet yes I'm like honestly I
just desperately need a vacation like
it's really catching up with me no yeah
I just like yeah I wasn't supposed to
work in June but like all these
opportunities came out because I don't
know if you know this Blake the toast is
the biggest thing ever like I went in
for a meeting with Asian sir like you
don't understand like just like working
on the ptosis could be my full-time job
it's like everyone wants piece of us I'm
telling you I know I feel finally not
going what judge exists oh man the other
thing I'm saying all weekend man plans
God laughs so true Mike literally just
look around man is planning and God was
laughing
okay back to Raven Adam loved them so
here for them I wish them a lunchtime of
happiness and I just know that that's
exactly what they're gonna get yes I
just I'm so happy and like what did what
a normal time limit
I'm so happy to think get engaged on TV
not that I ever thought they were going
to know they've had like a really normal
relationship like Genesis like
they've dated for two years and it seems
like a long time in bachelor world like
no that's a very normal amount of time
they met for two weeks in paradise
now they're gonna engage their families
are merging she moved to Dallas for him
like it's just it's beautiful yeah it's
beautiful mixed up speaking of beauty
Pete Davidson makes his modeling debut
as he walks the island Alexander Wang
show - cheers from the crowd okay so
Pete Davidson is a model now that was
like I'm so thirsty 90s boy bander oh he
looks like Kevin Federline when I first
saw this story I was like you know what
I actually think he's really
good-looking I'm here for this like and
he's like tall and thin and that's what
they appreciate in the modeling world
and then I saw the photo of him madelung
and I just I just didn't do anything for
me um but I'm glad to see that he's
having some shine like I want good
things for him you know I love him in
any way he can evolve past just like a
stand-up or he's being an actor now he's
a model I love it but just like as a
brand Alexander Wang he's like always
being thirsty like when James Charles
went to the mikela and he did a vlog and
they had like Alexander and James like
in the studio trying things I'm like it
was just so thirsty like I just feel as
if Alexander Wang like it's just dying
to be relevant and they'll take any
opportunity because they don't want to
miss it you know yes I feel as though
that is the case
often times oh my god wait someone
listened to 15 minutes of the Chosin
counted how many times we said like and
they said over a hundred I saw and I
just like needed a breakdown between how
much was you and how much was me yeah no
it was definitely would you're majorly
mean no but it's like is this something
that I like I know it's not my best look
but is it really a concern that I'm
saying 50 times in 15 minutes or banning
in 25 almost as if it was meant to be
time released an article saying the
people who say like a lot are actually
brilliant which I completely agreed with
and I definitely feel as if I am living
proof and it was almost as if it was
meant to be almost as if right okay
cause if it was meant to be it'll be
it'll be baby just let it be
and that's the other thing about Colgate
like that it's a wonderful place but the
one thing it doesn't have going for
where it should is the country music
vibe because it's such a vibe there and
there's like a lot of times we're just
sitting on a porch and like people want
to play Diplo and it's like no this is
the opportunity for some rascal Hudson
Somali yes people I call you have to get
their Rascal Flatts moly knob and I feel
as though everyone individually likes
country music so yeah it's it's not part
of the culture and it doesn't feel the
shame involved with being like hey
should we put on some dan + Shay I'd
look at the Shay and dad and shame um
wait also there was like 400 other
announcements I wanted to share via the
toast one we have new podcasts artwork
and I'm just feeling really excited
about it cuz you're feeling like an
artist you feel like an artist I'd like
spend so long making it last night like
on Photoshop like editing it things out
like with my little pen and it was just
it was exciting I hope everyone likes it
and then in celebration of that launch
we're doing a March giveaway on our
Instagram so if you head over to our
Instagram we're doing it for a few more
days you can win three people are gonna
win free merch and all you have to do is
subscribe to the podcast so leave a
comment on the Instagram so head over
there and check it out that is so
exciting I'm so excited to get my cam
toaster yeah a little bit exciting
things that aren't well exciting it's
just almost as interesting as
interesting actually it's true ready for
our next story which is so exciting so
interesting well now with that hype how
can I not be oh also we do a segment at
the end of this episode all the new
music that came out cuz I have like a
lot of thoughts sure mainly that by this
hard it's like has to stop making me if
I can just do something else no I'm just
two covers yeah yeah or go back to
country our backyard sessions back our
hooligans covers yeah third story yeah
gian giudice
and Frankie Tang and junior went to prom
together oh my god this was the greatest
thing ever I was following them at prom
the whole day and I heard a video on
choices story being like this is Frank
my daughter gia state and I'm like it's
impossible there's no way because we
literally called them on our Instagram
being the next potential big couple in
housewives history and then I started
literally stalking 11 year olds
Instagram from Jersey like of their prom
like looking at their tagged photos and
I found a [ __ ] picture of gia and
[ __ ] Frank Catania it's the best
thing that's ever happened to our world
they look so good to get like four
so it makes so much sense save so much
in common their moms are friends like
they on every level he's a little bit
older taking her to the high school prom
but she's really mature wise beyond her
years she's a senior
so he's in college they're like college
is funny and she is 18 there's nothing
that you learn appropriate me too and
there's nothing cooler than like being
that girl who like brings a college guy
to prom cuz like that guy must like you
so much if he's like slumming it with
high school kids you know and the food
punch so handsome like every time he's
on the show like everyone's just like
Frank Frank Frank Frank Yeah right
and like who's gonna get Frank no and
the fact that it's gia who by the way
I've now been stalking her is like
literally gorgeous like so tan blue eyes
like in amazing shape I think she plays
volleyball like I am so here for this
New Jersey royalty like if they get
married like and then she becomes a
house so I've like that would be the
most beautiful life cycle full circle
moment 1,000% and they feel as though
they are filming this oh they [ __ ]
better baby I mean timewise they
probably are filming it might be hard to
film at a pre prom with 50 other kids no
but I think those Jersey parents are
thirsty as [ __ ] they're like yeah I'll
sign the waiver let me like whereas in
Beverly Hills where everyone's like
really like secret and like rich or in
New York nobody would not allow in New
Jersey like all the moms like where do I
sign no 1,000% and and I want to see the
lead up to it like is Frank and ask Gia
how did this start maybe they were
flirting at that event where we took the
picture of them and when she looked so
[ __ ] cute axing since then and then
Dolores and Teresa what was their
involvement like and also gia looked
amazing I loved the matching lapel with
the baby blue handkerchief the bow tie
the whole thing it was truly like New
Jersey's finest it was New Jersey's
finest and I feel as though you know
this as New Jersey fans you know we've
had our ups and we've had our downs and
this is what we deserved oh so I'm gonna
say something mildly controversial about
page six
I feel like big we feel scared I feel as
if I feel as though yes thank you like
we made it such a yeah I feel like we
made it such a big day on our Instagram
and the toasters were like blowing it up
like I feel like nobody really would
have cared or written it up like if we
did make it a big deal maybe that's just
me being so self-centered and think in
the world revolves around me but I just
have a feeling no I agree because um I
knew in my head I wanted this to be
today but I haven't seen it anywhere
except for the Choson sir Graham and I
was shocked to see that they had written
it up um because no one has been like
their ship wasn't coming in you know
it's a buzz we during the actual prom
like the toasters were investigating for
hours like looking at stories of like
parents who were there like we
investigated found it out to be true and
then like an hour later was written up
on page six it's almost like they were
waiting for us to do the work so they
could take the credit we have to start
like a website like that becomes a
legitimate news source but like I just
don't want to write it I just want the
headline Franken geo and to prom
together at the end you have to like
kinda yes explain how you got I don't
want to also then Priscilla posted the
most premium photo I'm like that we will
forever be grateful Oh what was so funny
was that I couldn't find a photo of them
together and then the first person to
vote to pose was Priscilla who is
Teresa's makeup artist so I'm assuming
did Gia's face and I'm just so it looks
like she did Frank's face I'm just
wondering like if they were pissed
definitely not
I'd like I'm sure they wanted to post
first like either Teresa or Dolores or
Frank or gia and like Priscilla just
came out with the premium photo feel as
though they didn't even know the guy
they had three more like there was just
a random photo of Dolores Teresa Frank
and Gia just like someone was like
turning around like it wasn't like a
premium photo at all whereas like that
is the [ __ ] moneymaker they could
have sold that to People magazine for
$50,000 totally they should have done
literally like if people had seen
exclusive look at the pre-prom yeah talk
to some of the Perrigo where it's like
what do you think about this new hot
couple in town like ya know do you think
he's too old for her I would have stood
outside Teresa's house and like we're
like reporting on this story if I knew
that this was happening because it's so
[ __ ] yeah but where was after prom
right no where's where's Gia now no and
like what is their relationship was this
a friend happily on another friend right
maybe it was yet some tape bells on her
and Teresa's mom called Dolores
journalist to be sad about her daughter
and and Doris was like I'll kill you
what perhaps me the iPad but then maybe
then they saw so like I'm sorry the two
of them together like that it's just
such flames
there's no way it's not love I feel as
though you could tell a lot about their
relationship from their body language
and I have to say in this photo first of
all Frankie Tania's just literally
looking like Frank Sinatra like so like
those eyes and his hand is right above
her butt crack which is like oh we're in
love you don't get your hand above
someone's back pocket because if it was
really just a friend
beyond like her back yeah it would be
like under the arm
I'd like the shoulder blade yeah like
this but her even above the shoulder
well that's what her hit her hand cuz
she's standing on a step so she's above
him her hand is around his neck which is
like very friendly but I just think it's
an awkward position for her yeah I don't
know what I'd like to me they just Gina
they look like they jeah later we shared
Priscilla's Instagram and she captioned
it and that's a wrap with two blue
hearts I'm gonna see what people are
saying like on Instagram or like is
everyone freaking out they have to be I
mean this photo got something like I got
ten thousand likes that is so many if
that is so many I mean I just I've said
Theresa tagged 1 million brands I can't
even find Gia okay now I found Gia she
posted a different photo where they're
holding hands look they are holding
hands oh my god you don't just hold
hands no this is not this is not friend
this is this is more now here's the real
thing
did Frank post it okay and also yes he
posted a slideshow one two three four
okay four photos the first photo is them
by the pool of what do I haven't seen
before his hand is in the friendly back
position then posted the photo of them
with their moms which is like he just
was thirsting out for Instagram
followers love third photo was him and
Gia holding hands on the stairs okay and
then the fourth was thirsty mirror pic
of him
what was his caption it said had a great
time last night at at gia Giudice senior
prom dot dot dot as always thank you to
Mouzone tuxedos for the tax you guys
have embarrassed I mean thank you to
[ __ ] mouths because like for that we
got the flames picture no I'm you so
grateful to tuxedos for like literally
tailoring this [ __ ] jacket and pants
to perfection where I could see the
outline of this bulge and his big arms
are busting out Tatiana and honestly
Thank You Mel zone thank you mother to
see this because this might have been a
last-minute thing like idealists of
their speculation that she and her
boyfriend rogue up and fridge barely
stepped in I mean Mouzone tuxedo stepped
in in a bigger way
interesting him for the occasion and
negative literally equally flake Jackie
this is literally the start to a Netflix
the young adult romance film starring
Noah Centennial where gia breaks up with
her boyfriend and then
mom's friends son coworker and is like
will you just stand in and they're like
so embarrassed such it's like fine this
guy then they end up falling in love and
the problem is that they're going to
college I'm like where do they go and
they're also on a reality show and like
this big morning show in their love and
they don't want to let them down no this
is like literally a fairy tale a fairy
tale now I just want to talk to our
resident prom expert because you've been
to prom the most recently out of any of
us here even too many a problem you've
seen the photos what do you think this
means who did you want to prom with the
first time was it a boyfriend yeah but
and the second time was a boyfriend okay
yeah she's a classy girl you know I
thought the photos were suspect and also
with her standing on the suspect
standing on the stair to make it like
more even with the height because I
think he might be shorter than her yeah
we're trying that's so true he
definitely is she what are you
suspecting I suspect that that there's
some love there oh okay so I didn't
might be in in the new state but this
was just like I think it might be in a
new state - and now and then all the
Psychopaths like aunts like making it
into such a big deal like Frank's gonna
get nervous so I'm just gonna shut up
which is one more time can't think
enough honestly if I don't hear from
someone from Malzahn tuxedos after this
about giving Ben a free taxi they're
like I'm gonna be pissed people no
longer be thinking that I will no longer
be grateful okay I'm like okay Nick
story Kylie Jenner's daughter stormy
hospitalized for an allergic reaction is
100% okay now Kylie Jenner's daughter is
on the mend after scary incident the 21
year old mom revealed on her Instagram
story Sunday that her daughter stormy
spent the day in the hospital quote she
had an allergic reaction
but is 100% okay now and we are home
nothing else matters when these things
happen god bless all the moms with sick
babies I'm sending so much love and
positive energy your way that is so
scary so scary
our she starts caring is the only way to
know that you have them is to like oh
boy am i right so I wonder what she's
allergic to know this is really sad but
I feel as if it's a great segue to
talking about something which is the
YouTube video Jeffrey started reviewing
Kylie skin was it was yesterday okay and
so you know Jeffrey star is like the
honest reviewer and he has reviewed
Kylie's products in the past he says
she's inconsistent but like some of it
he loves but he did like this he
saying when she had that 360 dollar
brush set and like tore it apart and
he's been since taken off her PR list
arms leave there's like underlying beef
just cuz like he's always tearing her
apart like why is she give me free
products to someone who isn't gonna just
lie and say they're good like everyone
else does um and he wasn't about its
Kylie skin and all the other youtubers
were so he was filming the video but the
you know Shane Dawson and he was saying
like they were filming something for his
channel and he was basically being like
everyone who's asking me to review Kylie
skin but I didn't get any for free and I
couldn't get it because it was sold out
and Shane Dawson is like a Kylie's Stan
and he was like wait like I literally
bought everything it's on its way it
should be here tomorrow so they ended up
filming using his stuff and like Shane
came in as like the [ __ ] obsessed
Kylie fan and in the video he was like
literally being so dramatic like about
all the products like he was the Kylie
stand and like he was being meaner than
Jeffery about the products it was really
pissing me off
and like they were trying to tear it out
but honestly it made it look really good
how so well what do you see what his
face they they like what they used it
all they said the makeup pads were a
little dry but in Kylie's defense they
only use the first one and the first one
in any pack is super dry so I don't
think that was a fair assessment then
they did the toner and they said a lot
of the products were really good but he
didn't like how it had added fragrance
in it cuz like skincare is not supposed
to have a fragrance because for if it
has the fragrance it means that it's
been added like with chemical think it's
a perfume that you don't need right but
like some people like that and I didn't
think that was a fair you know jab at
the brand either and then like with the
foaming face wash [ __ ] Shane Dawson
took 1 2 3 what literally 1,000 pumps
was putting it ever it got in his mouth
in his eyes he was being so nuts with it
like he was trying to be funny like
Santa Claus it was in his mouth I wanted
to throw up it was so disgusting and
then he said it's burning my mouth like
it was just such an unfair review I
really was getting annoyed especially
when the person who was like being so
like negative about it was a person who
was like the Kylie fan yeah
that's annoying so what was Jeffery
stars overall you know he's so shady
where like he and I've just like been
feeling so many different ways about him
when I went from like loving him to like
kind of doubting him it's like he will
like a product but just because he's now
in the space too he'll never say it he's
like this one he says he said I mean
it's good I'm not like a living for it
that's what I'll say cuz he never wants
to give a product like so much hype that
it could potentially take a sale away
from his business which
I totally understand but he Branson
stuff is I've got honest reviewer with
no strings to anyone and it's like well
that's not true now because you really
have like your own business and your own
interests which is fine but I don't
brand ourselves like the honest Rivera
so he was he was a lot more fair than I
expected him to be um it was fine he's
just like a little he was comparing it
to a $68 tatcha face cream and he was
like and he was saying how Kylie's
applicator is like the same as this
tatcha one and hers is 25 dollars and
there's a 70 and I'm like thank you I'm
gonna buy [ __ ] Kylie's it's
twenty-five dollars like yeah using the
price point of taja as a comparison was
so not fair literally actually making
her look better
I went to buy tatra and it was $68 and I
just couldn't do it for a [ __ ] face
wash I can do it I get my face wash at
CVS and I wash my face with Dove soap
like just clean your face
like it doesn't need to like it's not
gonna change your life so overall
consensus was that it was just basic
products like it was like he didn't say
this but I was just getting the vibe it
was like st. Ives like it gets the job
done but is it the best thing that's
gonna change your skin and keep you
looking like one of Paltrow know will
like moisturize your face and clean your
face to take your makeup off yeah that's
all you need unless it's lemare it's
just the basics they all of us they're
like it's the same formula as this is
what do you mean there's a is there more
than one way to make a face wash I don't
know yeah it was really annoying sorry I
just wanted to talk about that no I'm
glad that you did okay isn't final story
little business news maybe I don't know
Ben and Jerry's announces that CBD ice
cream could be coming student I just
felt as though as our resident resident
ice cream expert and our resident CVD
expert that's mine you might have some
thoughts on this um Ben and Jerry's is
jumping up the hair yeah Ben & Jerry's
is jumping on the CBD train or they plan
to at least the Vermont based is their
company announced on Thursday that CBD
ice cream is quote maybe hopefully
coming to a freezer near you the move to
incorporate the cannabis based compound
is a natural fit for Ben & Jerry's and
the statement posted to their website
they hinted at the at their affection
towards quote all things groovy though
many other companies are fusing their
products with CBD already
touting the elixirs wide-ranging health
benefits from anti inflammatory that's
what I need I'm inflamed as hell too
anti-anxiety
without the hi the problem remains that
the FDA prohibits from adding it to food
beverages and dietary supplements moves
are being made to change that though and
Ben & Jerry's is crossing its fingers
that is quite
honk and that seems like the sort of
thing that you should like buy and sell
stocks based on wait say that again the
FDA it doesn't allow you to put CBD and
food in food and beverages yet but there
are million companies that sell it that
sell it the nude chocolate
they're like CBD companies they're
probably not FDA approved as like in the
grocery store oh you're right you're
right it's they're like
direct-to-consumer CBD God but Ben &
Jerry's is an FDA approved but see this
is what it cuz all the the CBD foods
that I've tried are like mini like gummy
bears many chocolates where you have one
or two and it's like a full dose so is
one bite of this pint entire dress are
you have to eat the whole pint it's
definitely like and then per serving
size it's like but also it's like
everyone just eats a pint like when you
sit down so or at least I do so are you
just gonna get like really relaxed I
don't know this seems like a really
thirsty and weird of them the packaging
was really cute but it's like saying
your line you know like their CBD
experts like I don't need CBD in the
grocery stores I like having like these
specific companies I actually came up
with like a brilliant business idea for
I'm totally gonna start to CBD company
or like partner with someone and it
needs to be like snacky o's only like
gummy bears like little cute like
actually delicious snacks that also
relax you isn't that what you just said
our CBD snacks even it's like gummies
yeah yeah but it's like I want the
company to be only food like I don't
need drops you know like just snacks
snacks like chips I need to do it in
partnership with like Dylan's Candy Bar
yeah that's a great idea
yeah I just think it should be called
snacky Oh snacky Oh wellness for sure I
you're both gonna need some royalties
okay snacky a wellness that's delicious
yeah can't wait and it's just like
popcorn you like tasted movies it's like
also relaxing I love I went to one of
those movie theaters last night with
like waiter service and it was just so
[ __ ] premium I can never go to a
regular movie theater ever again I think
I should do that I think I should see
movie it's lemon lime and make a wish I
wish for happiness like this forever
actually not like this right now I was
feeling pretty good for a Monday I'm
feeling so horrible I need to go back to
sleep
I need probably CBD yes if you want o
kzv talk about seem you need so much on
the show on I never really tried it
until the other week and I didn't I see
something worst day ever happened oh my
god no I'm such a fan I take a gummy
laughing I'm like a fan of what I think
that it is but like it just didn't
really work for me yeah well maybe the
boats trying a camp is like giving it
like the hardest
you know yeah when you try it on a
peaceful Saturday okay I will I will try
that anyway my god I could do a CBD chip
which sorry I'm just like they have
ideas for my snack you like this company
the resident ice cream expert that's
right I felt as though you might give a
hoot about this Ben and Jerry story I do
give a hoot thank you for sharing those
are archive stories oh that wasn't
frustrate okay let's do a Spotify like a
recap because so much she means to came
out Katy Perry great amazing I'm like so
thrilled beyond words to have a normal
Katy Perry back no it's amazing and I
have to say I feel as if though she is
like Samson where we cut off her hair
and all of her power was gone but now
her hair is back and she's back to
making good music yeah no it was
definitely a tough time for a minute
there I want to go to my Spotify and I
was gone this weekend so I usually don't
listen to like new music cuz it's like I
want to bop to things that I know and
the first time I heard it I was like oh
this is incredible and it's already on
my playlist what is it the next thing
was the Camila Cabello Mark Ronson song
and like haven't heard it yeah I just
have to say like I think when Mark
Ronson was in Lady Gaga's documentary
making Joanne and then shallow like I
just assumed he was like the new Ryan
Tedder
but part of me now thinks that like
that's just the magic Lady Gaga I'm like
any producer would've made that song
because she's so brilliant because his
last two songs nothing breaks like a
heart which was mad and this camila
cabello one which is mad like I just
maybe don't think Margaret sin is
everything I thought he was no I think
that he is but I think it's like he can
only do so much with given so much and I
think women look at me go makes good
music
donkeys are Smith Lady Gaga he works
with Amy Winehouse he works with Bruno
Mars and like those are topics sure I
forgot about the Bruno Mars a uptown
funk he's actually like annoying now but
the greatest song ever and I agree um so
I think he can only when Miley Cyrus is
hell-bent on making bad music and
imagine what I've been without Mark
Ronson weirdness oh I thought that the
nothing breaks like a hard moment was
like not his fault because Miley's just
like not at all what she used to be but
then this coming like a Baio one was
also super disappointing cuz she's
really talented and her music is good I
haven't heard it yet I can't speak to it
I'll let you know my thoughts when I
have them okay
the next was Miley's EP which was like
six songs one of them is a bold eye on
estate I thought she just released one
song I haven't
no I listen to some of it people like
seem to like cattitude but I just I'm
such a Miley fan like really I am and I
just want good things for her and I
don't know if we'll ever get back to a
time and place where where we were with
can't be tamed or the backyard sessions
but this is not it for me like at all
and I don't like to speak ill of another
woman's career but just as like a stand
and a potential Miley's hand like I
stand Miley in all facets except for her
music and again I thought nothing breaks
like a heart was like fine but it was a
good stepping stones like better music
but this what we got is just not was
there an album in between can't be tamed
and bangers dead pets dead pets no no
there wasn't
okay so I feel like that was like a
moment week that was backyard session
yes
um but there before she cut her hair I
still think bangers was an amazing album
like it was definitely a departure from
what we needed from her but like there
were some wonderful sub grim dead pets
terrible younger now let's go to younger
now it was the same thing like nothing
breaks like a heart it was a good song
it wasn't amazing he'll be with album oh
I didn't listen to the album it was like
it was weird yeah it was like compared
to what we got now like you'd appreciate
it that's the thing it's like her like I
someone it was yeah I remember Malibu I
someone who's just like invested in her
and her career and should be invested in
her music like I didn't even know
younger and I was a full album like
she's so not she's an icon in everything
but her there's nothing a Connick about
her music or like her latest few albums
ya know it's really weird it's a but we
love her so much for like what what is
what is her trade yeah and then it's
like she it's almost like she knew that
she wasn't doing right so she parted
with the best Mark Ronson but it still
didn't work no and I feel like for a
long time in her career she was going
between being an actor and bringing a
singer and like she used to just focus
I'm acting and be like I'm not gonna put
it on that one for a while or she would
sing and be like I'm not gonna act for a
while but like she used to black mirrors
I was like okay maybe she's not gonna
sing for a while maybe she's learning
but she's doing both not well I do want
to watch her episode of black mirror gym
um has to come out has anyone heard any
go no in like whoa that'll be exciting
yeah I'm just like time and time again
like being let down and the Miley stands
are like trying so hard to make every
one thing like it's
and like I know that you know that it's
not but I won't make you say it cuz like
you're a good fan because like I
wouldn't make you saying about Taylor no
yeah and like honestly like I would
never but like I might be thinking it
you know right but I won't make you say
it cuz it's true Stan I think you know
what eventually a truce and we'll say
reputation I've said it but by the way
even reputation is an a-plus-plus
compared to some other crap people put I
don't know and not even that it's like
we're comparing it to the backdrop of
1989 which i think is one of the
greatest albums of all time read
fearless like we just know what she can
do so like we didn't think it was that
good but like as it stands like in
comparison to everything in the world
it's a [ __ ] great album oh my god
people are just like disagreeing with
Miley I have to tune off they can't
listen to this Miley bashing ok well I'm
done now I just I I had and I think I
know they're a lot of people who agree
with me but there's not as loud as than
my other stands and so for you I am your
I didn't know that it was even so
controversial I didn't know was either
to just say when music is good or bad
okay what else is out Thomas Wright
album let's get her oh my god it's red
ice Bert fantastic I really afterlife
changes I threw him to the curb because
it was just getting to poppy and like he
was he was so thirsty like like pop rap
I didn't just like stick to what you
know except we got grave which was worse
for the beautiful song
but then he was doing senator point road
and it really felt like he was going
back to his roots like with the album
and like the brown jacket yeah the color
so I was like okay maybe he's going back
then he released his songs before the
album remember you young and like I was
like wow this is where we're starting
like I can't even wait and then he did
that old truck which is like fine very
Blake Shelton like back to like pickup
truck that's like a radio you know but
it's like you're trying to go back to
country so that's why I mean and then
the album dropped and I just have to say
it is so good there are obviously some
songs like VHS which stands for very hot
summer Oh God what's the Carrie
Underwood song that we hate southbound
yeah yeah like it's like I wear my
summer shoes I wear my flip-flops like
it's all I'm just a soma girl I wear my
flip-flops and when I
let my hair down the party never stops
and who needs me I got a girlfriend and
when we get together never read am i
doing here in hilarious story always bet
a bunch of meetings last week and I'm
telling everyone I'm like really
hell-bent on the idea of having a
performer I can't just - I'll take quite
him yet
and I was with our agency and they're
like here's a list of our roster like
who would you potentially be interested
in and you know who they had on there
that I really made an asterisk hardcore
next to her name Leighton Meester
Leighton [ __ ] least her imagine she
came out like saying some country song
you know Country Strong like honestly
that would be just as iconic if not more
than lieu comes yeah see what the iconic
in a different way oh my god but you
were in the car on the way home
yesterday and I was just like getting so
tired of Rebecca playing Fleetwood Mac
and I was like I have to get migrants
into country like we love ever we love
all of the same things so I was like I
think this it's the time of the journey
there's beautiful vistas like I'm gonna
play country music and they were like
interested in hearing limb combs because
of how much we talked about him and so
like I did a nice like starter kit for
Luke Holmes I started with beautiful
crazy um what's the second one about
first one's for you one number away know
about a rails Boardman about a woman
it's like so about a woman she got the
best of me yeah oh that's such a great
song say did beautiful crazy she got the
best of me then I did this one's for you
and then beer number broke my heart so I
was like this is where right now like I
think I did they could make and I think
they really enjoyed it but it's hard for
people to listen to music that they
don't know other words so when I was
like sitting there like with chill I
know right it's like restraint not just
being like do you hear that lyric how me
I know they're trying to get people into
country it's like the hardest most
disappointing thing ever cuz like either
you have it or you don't but like for me
like I'm sharing these songs I think
like these songs are like a part of my
soul and like you're just like dumping
on and though it's really like emotional
and I feel very vulnerable and I don't
like to try and get people in to
contradict it whatsoever but I was just
really getting nothing and I'm like it's
like okay while I write you a song if I
know yeah if I ever like tried to
introduce someone to Luke Holmes and I
played when it rains it pours I'm like I
would have to stop everything but did
you hear that why yeah like she said
that lotto ticket right I wouldn't
[ __ ] but then he wasn't a lot of
he's on a redneck roll like he doesn't
have to talk to his ex future
mother-in-law anymore when it rains
[ __ ] [ __ ] and like you hear he
changed the octave also I got the best
email of all time you know that Luke
combs is doing a collab with Crocs they
asked me for my size oh my god I'm so
excited like I guess I wear Crocs now no
you they're cool they're cool
crunch by the way I'm behind on my
emails but I don't think I received that
he's really like he is brilliant
management like him he does the best
partnerships we can Kathy
yeah with weather tech like have these
seconds like the truck like the truck
mud things like perfect I bought like I
do you have Chuck and those shirts
yeah Crocs genius yeah this fishing
shirts I love when people just like oh
no they're audience you know yeah it's
like a bird it is like us in Sanford
because temper'd is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes a way for you to discover new
perfumes and clothes without buying an
entire bottle you can choose from more
than 450 designer brands for Saachi Tom
Ford product choose the perfume you want
they'll send you a 30-day supply that's
120 sprays which is enough to apply more
than four times daily for a month not
sure what type of scent you're looking
for you can sort and find your new
fragrance by brand style occasion season
and way more with our exclusive offer
you can get 50% off your first month
today at scent bird comm slash toast
that's only seven dollars and fifty
cents for your first fragrance that's
scent bird scen TBI RDECOM slash toast
and sign up for 50% off your first month
sign on ladies and gentlemen smell
amazing honestly with with all of our
new sponsors including Sanford like I
have really gotten it down to one shower
a week it's everything you can be like
to not have to shower and to smell good
and to be pretty like natural and yeah
and fresh I showered yesterday and I'm
think I'm set till Thursday okay that's
how I feel about washing my hair you
know I'll take a bath and like my meadow
twice a week hair wash scheduled me too
unless actually the bun I washed it even
less if I'm giving a fun season nothing
on the weekends like I'll just shower
like and wash my hair just for the sake
of like feeling clean but yes if I if
I'm busy like I literally wash my hair
like once a month yeah I'm gonna take my
spray tan now that I got for reading and
like it'd be nice to keep it for a
little exciting update when is June 6th
Thursday Thursday Thursday we have Jason
tar Tech on the toast
the vampire we're gonna talk to him
we're really excited about that I love
him I loved
vampire especially when it's the day
after right I'm talking to Charles from
younger is that much no no you booked it
yeah
oh you tell me I'm sorry I because I was
like just like I wasn't I did it and it
was like right before I headed out for
the weekend
oh my god I'm dead okay so Wednesday we
have Charles from younger mrs. Maria
Hargitay the Persil guy I'm dying and
then Thursday we have Jason Tariq oh my
god what a week what a week so I chose a
great week to start I saw that emails
like you see me on anything well I only
have to see CRP a now this is that's
below your pay grade wow I'm so excited
just make sure you marry different yeah
no we're teens that no one like honestly
they put on put on a color chart for for
Charles Howard yeah maybe who's your
simpered like watch your hair I love
your new shoes though so here you look
daddy Charles yes okay well I have to go
home and like freak out and I can
literally come up with a thousand
questions I'm gonna ask him like I feel
like it's a sweat more rich fella I'm
not gonna be annoying and I really do a
lot of questions that the new season of
younger like hey Charles like how are we
supposed to leave that believe that Liza
still 26 yeah but no now that's like
sort of Adam no I know but like there's
still people in the workplace yes who
well I think she's 26 I'm like I'm not
here to age shame but like like if I
were at work and like someone came in
and like okay I might have thought they
were something but they told me they're
26 like I would never like think that
they're not I also like don't care
enough about anyone else like really get
invested they investigate their age you
know yeah and some people's age is just
like so ambiguous like for older or for
younger so just like like it's also
believable
unbelievable that I'm 26 given how I
dress act and look it's unbelievable
that she's 26 like fine okay well thank
you to Marzano tuxedos for sponsoring
this episode of the toast
thank you toasters for listening make
sure you enter our giveaway if you head
over to our Instagram
first of all you should be following us
on instagram at morning toast of all we
have a giveaway running till Wednesday
three people are gonna win free merch
all you have to do is subscribe to the
podcast cuz we have new artwork and I'm
really excited about it
leave a comment on the post when your
that's pretty much it if you haven't
tuned into our new TN and show the
Schmitz head over to Apple Spotify
stitcher anywhere search to the ship
it's shb itz send it to your boyfriend
your husband like anyone who likes
sports I think they'll really like it
um we're launching a few more teen and
shows in the coming weeks really excited
about that and thanks to everyone who
likes sent me recommendations it was
actually really helpful like cool being
like I follow cuz like we're looking to
bring on new shows not anyone who's like
super big that already has a network but
someone who's like looking for the power
of the jost the power of the toast and
like just has some expertise that like
we could all [ __ ] use I haven't done
this a while so thank you guys for
tuning in to the morning shows the
morning Milan the Millennial morning
show
thank you guys so much for tuning in to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube um
are also available in the podcast app in
a podcast form on the podcast app
Spotify stitch our Public Radio I heard
any oh the whole thing
um so subscribe there enter our giveaway
listen to the tricks follow me on
instagram follow Jackie and Instagram
policy on Instagram I follow tiffany
thornton on instagram by and snitch yeah
you